you see, a leg was torn off
nuha, the inhabitants died a young girl, I’ll
definitely go 30 years old and killed in front of
my friend, together with the
little one,
supposedly we cut off access to all these and the
harness to the ipad as a slave, well, I’m with our
partners and it’s like sleeping standing on the
harness here  whom the karst of the Russian
Federation we have already completed this guilt we
have already turned mr and stronger our
territory in mind to bathe the bean 1
Ukrainian military so you taught something from the
wisdom of snares and about the state of
affairs in the fighters who defend Mariupol
everything is in normal high
morale to receive  carry out combat
missions, of
course, a lot of wounded and dead
guys,
more than 500 guys
require medical
support, the
situation is not a question, a very bad
basement, the guys are just new, in
general, as a boa constrictor in action, continues to
defend itself
as regards the statement of the Russian side
that they can finish
their activities in the near future that  regards mariupol
to such maybe this is a very real
situation groupie  the adversary is
tenfold tenfold there you are no more
superior to our equipment tanks
artillery and aviation
naval components
yes on the horse of history is calling
dangers and Kazan people and hundreds there is a
glacier women and children here very
small children
son also really needs help so they
also turned out to be traps  and is under
constant fire artillery strike
thanks for your attention and he and will continue to
capitalists pitch
with the
highest
i will say no
tank
rates
fm7 which is an bath your insides you
townhouse revision